hey youtubers it's Charlie so really
huge Game of Thrones news this morning
if you don't know what the tcas are that
they're basically like a giant press
conference where networks tell
Television Critics what their plans are
for the next season and answer any other
big questions people have about their
shows so Game of Thrones said that they
are committed to Season eight or I
should say HBO's said they're committed
to eight seasons that was always their
plan behind the scenes the actors have
only been signed to seven seasons so
that's you know why would I do a lot of
videos I'm mostly talking about seven
seasons but HBO is basically saying that
they will spend every ounce of Lannister
gold to Reese on the actors and get that
eighth season and that they're open to a
prequel they didn't say one was in
development but they said they really
really wanted a prequel like really so
what does this mean for this story well
it just means that they might be able to
spend all of that last season in the war
for the dawn is in like a 10 episode
drawn-out giant battle now I mean I
don't know that they would spend all 10
episodes doing that but they would just
dedicate that last season to this big
epic conflict that they've been teasing
for forever what does that mean for
season 6 in season 7 though well it's
totally possible that Jon Snow could
ride the bench for all of season six now
and then come back in season 7 I mean
they think you know they could have
someone dragged him off screen in the
first episode of season 6 and we just we
won't see him for forever if you've seen
any of my Game of Thrones videos since
the season ended you know I totally
think that he's coming back everyone
even on the TCAs panel this morning HBO
said everything that we have heard from
the producers says that he is dead what
does that mean well it just means that
he died it doesn't mean that he's not
going to be resurrected so just think
about it that way when people say oh
he's definitely dead they're not saying
that he won't come back they're just
saying that his body physically died
remember dead is not dead inside the
game of Thrones universe just because
the character is dead doesn't mean that
the actor does not come back in some
different form so Jon Snow aside what
about Daenerys because she still has to
come to Westeros there's still like so
much going on with her in the East right
now she's not even in Mereen anymore
she's gonna have to deal with all those
Dothraki for the early part of the
season and she still has slavers Bay to
fix
she's nowhere closer to accomplishing
that goal and in the dragons are
starting to get out of control so it
seems like she might be able to spend
all of season six and season seven
locking that down so she might not even
make landfall on Westeros with her army
to like the very end of season seven I
know it doesn't sound like it's that far
away but but think about it this way
season eight war for the dawn spring
2018 that's that's like a long ways off
if you have absolutely no idea what the
war for the dawn is I've already done a
couple videos some of the mythology
behind that so I'll put some links in
the description the really good thing
about eight seasons though is that it
just gives them more time to work with
George our Martin to incorporate things
that he's thinking about because even if
he's not done with dream of spring he'll
definitely be done with winds of winter
but dream of spring is the last book or
at least the planned last book right now
Martin has said that as he finishes
winds of winter he started to think of
new ideas that he didn't have before
when he was plotting out all the books
so there probably will be like a whole
bunch of stuff that happens in the books
that we never get to see on the show
just because the show will be done
before it's all over but Dan and Dave
still collaborate with Martin they still
talk to him all the time Martin just
isn't actively involved in writing
episodes you just have to remember that
the TV show has made some choices with
some characters like it's taken them off
of their book plots so they have to
resolve those so so there's certain
things that we'll see happen on the show
that are just a consequence of things
that they've already done Brienne and
Sansa are really good examples of that
like Sansa's book character is isn't
like a completely different place than
when her show character is right now
Brienne - there's even like a couple
characters that they've completely cut
out and we probably won't see Lady
Stoneheart being the biggest one
probably what's going to end up
happening you know because they've been
teasing the North remembers is that the
north itself will rally around Sansa or
try to and then they'll move against the
Bolton's like the north will deal with
itself like it always has but if that
ends up being similar to the book
narrative just expect a lot of
characters to get swapped for different
characters like the main characters on
the show will always play a bigger role
in the narrative than they do in the
books like Sansa right now like not a
huge book character I mean she's kind of
been sidelined for a little while but on
the show sophie turner is one of the
main actors so they're going to you
a lot more so given that eighth season
here just like a couple adjusted
predictions just you know like pushing
things out just a little bit more Arya
Stark probably gonna remain blind for
most of season six if not the entire
season do not expect her to leave the
company of jaqen H'ghar till at least
season seven King's Landing really big
stuff going on with Cersei that trial
like the trial with the faith probably
gonna take the entire season to play out
just think about like what happened with
Joffrey in season four and how Tyrians
trial took pretty much the entire season
he didn't escape to the finale so just
just expect that a similar timeline for
Circe's battle with the faith with any
luck Jaime will kill her with a crossbow
while she's taking a dump I've kind of
already explained Jon Snow
I feel like Melisandre has to do
something in the first couple of
episodes we'll learn pretty quickly
what's going on with Jon Snow you know
whether or not they decide to resurrect
him next season or they're gonna push it
out to season seven kid Harrington has
been near the set way too much for it to
be a coincidence even though people are
talking about him cutting his hair like
he didn't cut his hair he trimmed his
hair like a little bit so don't flip out
it if you're like one of those hair
watch people I don't really consider
myself part of that but but it is
relevant and what about the Dorne
storyline that everyone was a little
disappointed with so yeah they'll
probably spend more time developing
those door--and characters which i think
will be good for everyone they didn't
spend a whole lot of time with the sand
snakes or with Duran Martel Duran
Martell is one of the most interesting
characters in the books we just met him
so hopefully we'll get to see a lot of
him in season six also in the South
Samwell in Old Town he'll probably end
up spending all of season six in and
around the Citadel that it looks like
they're casting his family basically
randyll Tarly really big character I've
spent a couple videos talking about him
proper Baratheon Stannis Baratheon
pretty much anybody of any worth in
Westeros acknowledges him is this
amazing battle commander so I'm really
hoping that he gets rope back in with
this war for the dawn stuff going in
Season eight samwell's importance to the
narrative is more as an advisor like
he's the person that comes to you
telling you how to beat White Walkers
like you need to use these weapons you
need to use these techniques
really big long shot if anyone's hoping
for any scenes to you know confirm Jon
Snow's parentage you know if Rhaegar
Targaryen Lyanna stark were his parents
I actually I think the really exciting
thing that the show would do logically
is they would show us rather than tell
us like some some character wouldn't
read it in a note you would just you
would see it in a flashback or you would
see Jon Snow resurrected and something
would happen that would very clearly
indicate who his parents probably were
they might choose to push that out but
they were there were too many teases in
season five for it to be coincidence the
show will continue to explain what
happened during Robert's rebellion
either in flashback or with other
characters remembering things there's
still at least two characters that could
probably know what happened to Lyanna
stark and one of them is still stuck up
in the north underneath the tree so
based on HBO's saying that they're gonna
do anything they can't like everything
they can to resize the actors for season
eight what do you want to see happen
with the story between season six and
seven like do you think they'll spend
all of that final season in the war for
the dawn what about the prequel that
they were talking about though that they
didn't say anything about storylines but
the slam-dunk the the easy safe bet
would be to do a Robert's rebellion
series the show has spent a little bit
of time talking about it like it like it
hasn't completely spoiled everything
it'd be one of those series where you
know even more people have a pretty good
idea of what's going on they just they
don't know what it looks like so it'd be
very familiar so I feel like it'd be
very popular at least at the beginning
there's always a lot of things that they
could choose to not do on the main show
to spoil stuff that happened during
Robert's rebellion or to go with their
interpretation that that'd be a
situation where George R Martin would
have to step in and say oh look you know
this is what happened even though I
haven't written in the books this is the
way I planned for things to go whatever
story they decide to go with it would
have to be something that could last as
long as the game of thrones main show it
would have to be something that could
last for eight seasons and when you look
at the actual timeline of Robert's
rebellion it didn't last anywhere near
eight years like there's there's not
quite enough material so they would have
to adjust things quite a bit that's
another really good question
like if they did Robert's rebellion but
there wasn't enough material would you
rather than just go ahead and do it and
there only be like four seasons of a
prequel or would you rather
do something completely different like a
completely different storyline and have
it go eight seasons even if you're in
high school right now you like by the
time you see the final episode of the
spin-off series of the prequel series
you would probably have a child you
probably be married with the child
that's how far away that is and if they
did confirm one we would probably hear
about it before they start production of
season eight of the main show so I don't
really expect any spin-offs talk any
serious spin-off talk from HBO at least
until next year so just a quick reminder
because this was kind of unexpected I'm
just gonna add a round of the giveaway
so all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment of this
video the next one will start whenever I
post my next bonus video on Sunday when
I do the Q&A next Monday I'll just all
announce two winners that's the only
change and because like this happened is
I was working on a flash video tonight I
I do have a new flash season 2 video
coming don't worry there's there's
plenty other stuff coming tonight
it's just that everyone collectively
poop their pants about a half an hour
ago when HBO was like eight seasons in a
prequel so while you guys wait for all
that stuff you can click here to learn
all about resurrection and the Game of
Thrones universe and A Song of Ice and
Fire
and you can click here to learn all
about the war for the dawn thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you